so here's the most important question
maybe for our viewers they hear two
trillion dollars big number obviously
there are a lot of industries are gonna
be help they need it right now but it's
the workers who need it most
how quickly do you think you can get
checks out forget about the two trillion
dollars people are wondering about the
$1,200 to $2,400 for a family and we're
hearing reports this could take weeks it
could get complicated in a bureaucratic
are you worried how quickly can people
get the money I was told two to three
weeks and you know one the bipartisan
agreement is the working man needs help
right now and that's what that direct
cheque assistance is designed to do but
we think within a matter of weeks people
will have the $1,200 for children 500
but I think at the most important
provision in my judgment is a small
business loans that involves about the
loans and the tax provisions they can
help small businesses stay afloat and
with cash flow and liquidity so they
don't lay off all these workers we're
trying to get through really the next
some say 15 days I say two months really
of a crises where we can keep them
afloat so they don't go under so that
when we do rebound out of this crisis
these companies will still be in
existence and the jobs will still be
there and people will not be on the
streets we also have pandemic
unemployment assistance for those who do
not qualify under that provision and so
we want to make the the in the
workingman whole right now we want to
keep the job to intact we want to keep
the small businesses afloat until we get
through this